stop the presses gang got a special
announcement the middle class famous
tour is in full effect hey your tickets
me the bald one the long hair we're
coming to a city near you bring the
squad out it's a great way to introduce
people to the show you get to see some
stand-up you get to play a little ayg
with me in the gipperino it's a good
time hit me out yeah guys we're going to
be in atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh
buffalo detroit denver phoenix salt lake
city chicago rose man guys it's a great
time can't wait to see you out there get
your tickies now yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is r
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out they
grew up to be classy birthday just a big
old piece of trash i'm your host stage
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
down here in aunt tony's basement she's
upstairs slice the elios rolling rock
pony and a percocet okay my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the ceo of are you garbage he is an
international businessman he is not to
be trifled with but he's my best pal in
the whole world and i love him give it
up for kevin james ryan hey love you too
pal i'm like cut that saliva
like i don't know did someone ring a
bell or something
[Laughter]
uh hey gang thanks for tuning in as
always
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes please full video available on
youtube as you know those numbers are
true now more than ever they're true to
the roof shout out to that timmy
that kid's got a [ __ ] motor guy owns
the internet oh x insane oh man that kid
can do some numbing
kids selling picky
and then obviously i would be an [ __ ]
a jerk off a
[ __ ] bozo if i didn't mention the
greatest website of all time shout out
to al gore for inventing the internet
shout out to samyam jack conte
for patreon.com
are you garbage baby check it out get
bonus bonus episodes ayg a whole nother
podcast
by the way is everybody's favorite
podcast
hard feelings on that 10 level
and then obviously we do live streams
with uh our top tier patrons the whole
nine yards check it out you were talking
to patreon patreon called me the other
day how crazy is that
you choose okay
patreon called the kid how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good
t-bone mcmuffin it's toby mcmullen
what's up dudes what's up good friend of
mine hell yeah good friend of yours
who's got nothing but the vibes are good
vibes are good there has been
discussions of a toby cam
by toby actually is weird enough broad
they brought it up
then we got a hoodie cam
she's already got one on only fans but
still
one for the public uh
yeah we might do a toby toby cam all day
yeah he'll be cam all day yeah you gotta
lose that bear's flag though yeah we'll
have to do some uh we'll have to do some
red i can't be i mean i'll let you have
the bears flag off screen but this is a
bird's household through and through
okay
tony doesn't know that's up but if we
start broadcasting a [ __ ]
chicago bears cody's gonna have some
issues with it social security checks
just start drying up in the mailbox
they don't play down here in south
philly toby
is that where we are
i think so okay just checking i don't
know sometimes i was blindfolded and
brought here i don't know what's going
on we come in every day like the bat
cave
i entered through the waterfall down by
the stadium
speaking uh
speaking of crazy um
i we're your hosts
[Laughter]
i picked up a little bit of another
little tidbit uh
okay what did i say i don't know i
picked up another little tidbit um from
patty from your mother from my mother
uh-huh uh something i didn't know no i
known abroad 45 years
i
i know she's a little squirrely she's a
good kid though makes a hell of a cuddy
make a hell of a cutlet um she's
listening to this too so she's [ __ ]
walk carefully are those world world
famous bluebells shallow fried cuddies
shallow fried cuttings shallow fry yeah
shallow fried finished in the oven
finishing the fryer
double finished in the fryer
um
what i guess they got they got a hot
ticket going down there with the lottery
in p.a i guess the numbers are up okay
well the numbers are up everybody get
everything there's a lot more every dirt
bag off a pull-out couch
everybody is involved talking about it
talking to the guy at the [ __ ] how
would you but you know it's only 50
million after taxes that's the biggest
dirt ball line any time it's cooking so
there must be a hot one because um
sorry saturday
and she's like henry
where do you think can i borrow 10 grand
it's for my numbers
she said what do you think
the luckiest part of the refrigerator is
what yeah to put the magnets on to put
this to put the tickets oh my god in a
magnet now you can't teach that kind of
dirtbag level hold on there is some
religion involved in it because there's
different saints oh i was thinking it
was going to be lab coats and white boys
yeah
oh i didn't know there was different
saints in your refrigerator why didn't
you say something henry there's dude i'm
sitting over here like an [ __ ] didn't
know [ __ ] st thomas was in there
there's different mass cards with saints
on them around around the uh
around the refrigerator and things are
placed what does the patrons say to
scumbags
is it patty
tom barrages
so i don't know what's really going on
ah
and i i've just discovered this that she
puts things around with the different
saints to where the good juju is oh my
god if it's something with the kid she
puts it over towards this i get i guess
on a hot streak
you know she puts it over with whoever's
got the hot hand in the dice game
talking about that clackity clack let's
go
picture away no amy no emmy no amy so i
i discovered that and i got a scratcher
from her which i hit five probably not
gonna see a dime without money wait so
what do you do when you hit five you
give it back to her yeah give it back to
her let her let her handle it well we do
because it's pa yeah sure if it was up
here i'd take it this is a gentleman's
move performed by my stepdad many a year
and he still doesn't he's big on his
scratchers he's a little trashy uh real
big on the scratchers i'm talking like a
couple hundo christmas morning what is
that film made of because it's like it's
fascinated me since i was a child it's
it's it's like you know wax no it's like
aluminum foil type stuff it's like a
it's like a
a metal type you know there's some sort
of something in there she tried to give
me a penny too
what i'm a quarter well that's bad luck
you need ridge you can't be doing
scratchers with a penny if you used a
quarter that would have been a five g
hots no i think a quarter is what you do
quarters the move yeah of course so you
can't be doing a penny dude the top
result on what is the scratch-off film
made of on google is one word technology
period
there you go
out of space technology
i don't know how to i can't explain this
technology
i don't know how to write the shamrocks
and the cherries underneath that [ __ ]
that's what i don't know how come the
hair how come the child come the
cherries aren't coming off with the top
layer
what's the icing made of you tell me
that
i've never seen a four-leaf clover
my my step-dad he operates as like a
liaison or the bank really he buys the
he buys the ticket off of you yeah so if
you hit for five
or 10 or 15 does he cash checks too
he pulls you get a payday loan from this
guy everybody it adds up what you got i
got two i got what sorry let me ask you
this he gives these out he gives them
all out to everybody and then and then
so like if it's christmas sure i'm his
nephew or whatever granddaughter i come
hang out here you go buddy here's a
couple of scratchers for you i hit
he takes them he gives me the money and
then he goes and deals yeah that's the
[ __ ] classiest [ __ ] thing that's a
one-stop shop right holy [ __ ] yeah so
say you went for a five goes i got you
give me the call give me the winner he
checks too he checks because he makes
sure it's a winner he's got the scanner
he's not i might burn him a couple of
times if we're being honest there's a
there's a couple december 26th where i
got a phone call tell me it was a
hundred grand you won a dollar
uh he pays you give me the winner put
the winners over here and then oh you
gotta fight it's like a casino i know
becomes your room too
once you have a little breakfast on us
tomorrow morning hey sugar tits make the
eggs like the kid likes them
dude that's [ __ ] insane yeah
it's cool he does it right he does it
right you of course i give it back to my
mom i'm not [ __ ] going to whatever
yeah but she should just give you the
five b oh i mean we're not that's a half
a pack of bernies he's he's the borgata
she's the tropicana all right she's
played by different rules on the other
side of atlantic city all right we're
not down there on the water she's a big
shot all right we're back baby you guys
are inland
[Laughter]
you guys are up by vineland dude no [ __ ]
yeah she doesn't and she doesn't have
the kind of capital to be doing
the five claims on it
but i'm just saying most of the times
you get those things
and it's all right yeah you know to you
you turn it in because when you get even
like a gift card or something like that
there's a job involved there is you
gotta go build something yeah yeah yeah
but to have the [ __ ] foresight
and the class i know that's that's
honestly one of the classiest things
like what a [ __ ] gentleman because
it's the holidays it's like you're not
really getting the reward of the thing
sure but you're getting the fun of
scratching the thing and then you get a
couple of couple [ __ ] paid right
there couple of [ __ ] does he does he
take anything like if you win five bucks
does he give you 475 no there's no
shipping and handling nothing he doesn't
even wet his beak on it yeah yeah damn i
think oh what hit the scam he might be
he's fully we'd be looking i'll give you
three you know i'll buy it for you for
three right now how are you gonna get
there yeah exactly
what he might do
this
this might be because he you know
uh
is this calculated
he might keep uh the free tickets
if you would if you win a free ticket
he's not paying you that's not a cash
that's not a cash prize what are you
doing they're going i'm not gonna drive
the [ __ ] wawa for a one two dollar
ticket
he goes i'll take the freebies so he
might get all the freebies back and then
go parlay and see if he can get some
action see if he can sit at a big table
you know what i mean see how harden's
playing things he's also looking for an
excuse to go have a [ __ ] bernie
outside of my mom's you know outside of
my mom's radar i gotta go cash in the
dick he's down there [ __ ] he's got
winston's cooking those dudes tend to
those guys tens tend to hang too
we're at the at the ticket wherever they
get to tickets well he doesn't play it's
m it is just a very uh christmas type
thing uh oh he's going to scratch your
guy all year yeah not full
no he wouldn't put piss money away like
that he's moonlighting
yeah he's a one time one time here and
he plays the bank too you know nice he's
a good guy i like that that's
that's pretty [ __ ] nice right when i
do a scratcher i'll do them on the road
just because you're like ah it's
something to do and it's like rarely
i'll do them
but you do them before you leave the gas
station
whatever i'm not getting i'm not taking
connecticut scratchers to the hotel than
to take i'm doing it there so it's
probably when you're grabbing let's see
if you can put a couple pieces together
you know what i mean that's why when
you're grabbing a snickies there's
always some guy next to the line [ __ ]
yeah trying to get that [ __ ] off there
for sure
anyway i was i was unaware that we were
in that level
of
craziness
i
around the fridge i love you patty yeah
at blah blah who who won no i don't know
who won what not i think i mean what
saint got well you know what saint has
the has the hot real estate right now it
was in the top right corner i don't know
who that is i don't know who the saint
is
dr j
yeah that's allen iverson
we're talking about lotto
i'm not sure but i'll be looking for my
taste if it hits obviously that's the
thing i'm sitting here talking [ __ ]
right now about the poor woman of course
who i love to death of course we both do
shout out to patty that's the difference
between me and you you quote dr j and i
say helen iverson if that's not like the
biggest discrepancy of our of our comedy
and references being born in different
decades
10 years older than you i'm aware
a good kid dr j was our guy yeah i know
um
whoa whoa we're in the metaverse are we
i don't know
you don't know what's going on i don't
know what's going on but anywho let's
get into some garbage questions let's do
it from our good folks over there our
good homies the homies on the patreon
guys when you send up when you sign up
for the patreon we'll answer your
garbage question whenever we get hit up
a bunch it's just the best way to do it
the homies over there on patreon get
first crack at it and that's what we've
been calling everybody if you're if you
listen to the free episode you're a bozo
if you listen to the patreon you're a
homie but we love all these we love all
you through and through baby and we know
a lot of people push the patreon i'm
telling you we're having a good time
over there it's a fun it's a good time
it's a good group of fun i'm telling you
i'm telling you it's good stuff uh this
one's from stanley just says shorts in
the winter question mark oh yeah ah you
were never that guy were you i was never
that guy growing up but now that i've
reached my full potential
is that what you've been calling it
well i've reached mixed capacity there
is a
line of fatness that you cross where you
can become that guy and it's really just
about self-insulation
like you like you got to be it's also i
don't think you have a lot of pants that
fit
sure it's uh sure it's a fabric issue
it's not my legs don't get cold no it's
i'm not playing you know as a bigger man
you're not you're not rolling in pants
no ants are few and far between i'm not
but if a fat guy is cold a fat guy's
cold a fat guy's not gonna go out there
he'll go out and get himself a pair of
sweatpants and not go out in shorts if
he's cold i'm telling you it doesn't
affect us the same way
i don't even know if i'm still human you
were just shivering outside you were the
one that wanted to come inside shivering
i get to chill every now and again but
i'm telling you if i have to leave my
place to walk to the deli or something
like that together that's different i'm
talking about like going to school high
school in shorts no i didn't go to high
school in shorts my legs are terrible
there's chicks there what do you mean
i can't get any chicks out walking
around your shorts yeah i didn't have
that uh yeah i never i never did that i
was never big on that i was never even
the kid to like pushed it early you know
what i mean you'd have that while like
you know march 2nd or something it'd be
getting kind of nice it'd be like 55 and
some kid would wear shorts like shorts
were different when i was a kid though
they were we were still in the show i'd
love to hear this take we were just
they went down past the knee we didn't
know what we were doing they did they
were like bigger and like bloomier they
were different now these kids are
wearing tighties
wearing short shorts i know i can't pull
them off no even like regular bozos i
remember seeing pictures of cookouts and
stuff last summer with the [ __ ]
hawaiian shirts they're all wearing
[ __ ] short shorts you got fat guys
wearing short shorts yeah [ __ ] this
world coming
get a pair of hand ones
hit the deviled eggs
like a [ __ ] gentleman
can't do it all right this one uh but i
do say the cold is i've i've reached the
fatness where the cold doesn't affect me
as bad mm-hmm it's probably an artery
thing i would assume i think it's a
blood flow circulation yeah yeah yeah
which you know
it's almost like a superpower yeah
i'm surprised when do you get those like
tough looking ankles that people that
those fat guys get you see them walking
oh i got them do you know what i
mean i believe you're referring to
cankles yeah no not i mean i know what a
cankle is obviously but i'm saying the
skin gets it's a blood flow issue
referred to as lymphedema yeah yeah it's
when the blood doesn't go
ah does it get better
well when do you get it that's what i
want to know because the second you do
i'm done you weren't done this i stepped
off a three-minute [ __ ] plane ride
what are you talking about i look like
i'm on my way to bingo
i swell up like [ __ ] i gotta start
pushing christmas i gotta start pushing
you around
come on tighten it up you are please for
the listener also too uh
i am very proud of the the work you've
been putting in [ __ ] it in the gym man
toby cut that ag-1 shout out to it no
no no not this week i don't think
people plus baseball just stop testing
people if they're juicing yeah oh wait a
shot what are you going to think what
are you going to get in no try try the
twilight years no but roids are going to
come back in style
i think they've always been in style get
all juiced up yeah some d-ball with me
go old-school i see
[Laughter]
it's called lymphedema it's when your
heart doesn't pump strong enough to get
the blood back up
um
[Music]
it's in my family
not shocked
like a cousin in the back of a
thanksgiving photo but will your feet
turn all right like your extreme it's
your feet usually the blood collects in
your ankle it turns all red and stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah they sell they sell
things they sell i know the tights i
know yeah yeah no the things that you
hook up and and they massage the lights
yeah my dad's got him
yeah they called as legs things and i
use them all the time they're called as
leg things yeah is that the medical
knowledge you just dropped they're
called as leg things
you guys you get that out there they're
called leg things but it's awesome talk
about self care you sit in that thing
for an hour it really feels good it
really gets it gets things moving people
do it now as preventative care like like
in shape people are doing it
i'm not a scumbag he's not wrong like
all these athletes [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
yeah there you go i didn't say anything
oh foley house he's [ __ ] in pt we're
getting [ __ ] tight over there sure
telling you crazier than ever too
[Laughter]
foley which of these dumbbells are the
lucky
ones somebody put my leg things under
the lucky washing machine
i want to fill them with superpowers
kip let's talk about ladder ladder gang
a lot of people get scared away when it
comes to term life insurance but with
ladder they can help you if something
ever happens god forbid you don't want
to leave your loved ones holding the bag
get over the ladder easy peasy yeah got
to make sure everything's in order
ladder is 100 digital no doctors no
needles no paperwork when you apply for
3 million in coverage or less just a
couple of minutes phone laptop to apply
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find out if you're
instantly approved uh if you prefer to
talk to a person they also have a team
of licensed agents that doesn't work on
commission so they're not going to try
to upsell you just find out the best fit
for you know what i mean
finally since life insurance costs more
as you age now's the time to cross it
off your list so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life dot com slash garbage
ladderlife.com garbage
athletic greens athletic greens athletic
greens i love you i take you every
single day uh-huh until my free trial
runs out
[Laughter]
and i'll be begging for more uh dude
it's [ __ ] awesome man gut health
immunity mix it with a little water you
shake it up they send you a little thing
like a little a little cool little sure
what's it called a thermos that comes in
oh water thing unbelievable shake that
up drink it tastes great i love it yeah
it's fantastic uh i mean that it's like
it's like a super uh multivitamin it's
got everything you need in it uh it's
lifestyle friendly whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten-free
contains less than one gram of sugar got
you covered no gmos no nasty chemicals
no artificial flavor anything it still
tastes good
uh it costs less than three dollars a
day so it's cheaper than your cold brew
habit so right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into flu and cold
season just one scoop in a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills hey did i take
it did i not it's easy peasy
uh for you to look after your health uh
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune support
and vitamin d that i take every day look
at that five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com garbage again
that's
athleticgreens.com garbage to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
do it yeah this one i don't think we've
i honestly don't think we've ever talked
about this this is from rambo two
different words um
is a bunk bed with the bottom bunk of
futon garbage
do you know what i mean it's got like
the full-size
queen or whatever full that like
has the kink in it that turns into a
couch
which when they dropped i think that was
so cool like you mean when they dropped
when you were in eighth grade and one
kid got it in his room that he didn't
have roommates or anything like that in
eighth grade i'm just saying whenever it
was when he was a kid i just remember i
had it was
it was like the new version of bunk beds
where you're like you we had me and me
and danny had regular bunk beds did they
go did they go parallel or do they go
out perpendicular that was another cool
that was like a sitcom thing nobody had
the perpendicular [ __ ]
they were with like a desk under it or
something that that was [ __ ] that was
like boy meets world [ __ ] that wasn't
the ryan they were nice we had ones that
were like from my older cousins from an
army barrett that we lost the we lost
like the pegs remember you put the pegs
in yeah you have to lift it up and then
it would sit on the pegs we lost the
pegs and we used lincoln logs
shout out to the lincoln law
yeah the most versatile
toy uh-huh we used lincoln logs to hold
them up meanwhile my mom couldn't lift
the bed so it was me and danny i mean he
was like he was eight i was four and we
were lifting a [ __ ] set of bunk beds
out it was dangerous in that
there was no man around
between my dad leaving and my stepdad
coming in there was a lot of manual
labor done by children
[Laughter]
we were moving couches and [ __ ] did you
ever have to call a neighbor over to
help you or anything i don't think we
were very resourceful yeah that's a
tough thing i got called a [ __ ] if i
wasn't able to do it i remember being
like it's a pull-out couch and i'm sick
what are you i'm not a [ __ ] dragging a
cooler on the beach this is a i had a
similar question i thought of that i
wanted you guys opinion on top bunk
bottom bunk
older kid would get the top one that's
what he it was cooler that was cool it
was more dangerous yeah you want the top
bunk yeah you you you got the bottom i
was always bob i was scared up there oh
man
that's where the boogeyman will get your
first
batting spiders no thank you
ceiling was always too close too i felt
like i felt like i was in a coffin
oh i got the big man's number today what
am i [ __ ] houdini up here
laying there in a straight jacket get
the [ __ ] out of here hey kill bill i'll
be on the couch all right i'm just
punching the ceiling doing the six inch
punch no but i'm thinking like is it
trash yeah it's trash but it's not trash
if it's in a single kid's
room he doesn't he doesn't have a
brother but if one if you're one if you
like yeah if you have to sleep no yeah
you're folding the couch back up every
night to pull the bed out that's that's
trash yes for sure in any situation
sure yeah of course but one step away
from a murphy bed if you have one
if it's just you if you're in like sixth
grade and you sleep on the top and you
have the and your room's like a hangout
that's dude [ __ ] top-notch dude you
wanna sleep over i can pull this out
what you pull this out yeah i remember
one of my buddies had the bed that came
out the trundle bed i think they were
called yeah i he pulled that out i was
like dude and it was in the farmhouse of
the neighbor remember how the farmhouse
where like you know in my neighborhood
or like my town area
it was all farmland and they would all
the farmers sold the land to developers
but kept their house
sure and these kids lit moved into the
farmhouse so like every like
neighborhood has a farmhouse in it with
all that they always had to go hardcore
with the farm decor yeah and dude
it was that place trundle beds and
rocking chairs oh sickles too hanging on
the wall and [ __ ] it was dicey
first place ever saw a hologram too
freaked me out his dad was in like
graphic design or something he's like
look at these i'm like dude it's giving
me a headache i gotta go home
have a slice of [ __ ] helios and clear
my [ __ ] head
i gotta get back to some place with
electricity
you guys are bugging me out yeah [ __ ]
over here churning butter dude
um
but he pulled out a trundle bed and on
my mind
i think i didn't sleep over i was out
weirded out just because you're looking
at bed and then all of a sudden another
bed comes out of it it comes out and you
you can either i was afraid i was going
to get closed in that's why i wasn't
doing it if he slides it out then it
goes in and then i'm in there
spring-loaded i'm like i'm like the
japanese businessman in seinfeld
sleeping in the furniture sleeping in
the fargomen um
you can either you can you can pull that
out and keep it one level below and
sleep on that that's pretty cool that's
a good snuggle situation dude goofing
around and stuff like that you're just
one of those but yeah you know what i
mean yeah um grab ass yeah or you can
raise that up and it's a huge bet oh i
didn't know that sleep deal and sleep
yeah that's not bad yeah
plus back in the day that was the excuse
oh we're not sleeping together if your
lady friend stayed over
you had a trundle bed like my my high
school girlfriend's parents did
in in in my in our later years real
freaky
yeah well that was a little bit of chaos
i never saw one i was a little bit of
kid really yeah somebody moved out and
then
their room gets turned into the nice
guest room i think that had a trundle
bed if i'm even saying it right is it
maybe it's tumble bed it's trundle bed
trundle trundle did any of your friends
have the coffee table where the top is
like comes up on the springs oh
someone did have that i forget who it
was a triangle
so it was a cough it's a coffee table
and the top like lifts up so it like you
know at a coffee table you sit there
it's not you can't like
use it you can't like eat off of it
you're like hunched over sure this
elevates and comes oh look it had a tv
tray yeah it's like a standing desk kind
of that's not bad comes to you so you
can
operate on it my aunt had one had a
coffee table that was circles and it was
one circle and then a circle underneath
and a circle underneath and you could
fan them all out
real nice yeah
real nice it's all right
not too
bad shout out to raymore and flanagan
we had a wooden one right but in the
wooded it was like uh four
big squares of glass right
and
oh man this is so i forgot about this it
was four squares of glass like big pains
like you know 18 inch by 18 inch or two
feet by two feet or whatever big [ __ ]
panes of glass and we broke them
habitually
like consistently broke these putting
your feet on the coffee table feed on
them sitting on the corner changing the
whatever you can't have glass like that
a glass coffee table without a teenager
yeah because you want to break i'm not
even saying teenager i mean we were like
kids you want to break it we'd be like
wrestle on the couch fall over i mean we
broke it multiple times and then at once
but in your head you always wanted to
see what would happen if you shattered
it i don't know about that i mean i
don't think i'm a
[ __ ] crazy person what's going to
happen when i shatter these clays i
think you're hanging with it you think
you're buddies with a guy
because i always think that about the
sliding glass doors in the bathroom i've
never thought about that once in my life
oh i always want to throw a brick
through it and see if watch it shatter
no
all right looting the head and shoulders
yeah you just described every
relationship i've known you had i like
to watch it burn
i like to throw a wrench in the mix and
see what happens torch this place um
but we broke it so many times and then
well the one of the replacements was
like temporary to get the glass cut or
something and it was just like a piece
of plastic like from like a hockey rink
it was like it was
it was like the we just kept that for
like a decade that's brush and it was
like you could you could you couldn't
see through it it was like foggy and
stuff it was a bad luck coffee tables
get real trashy after a while yeah
they get [ __ ] up
start pulling apart falling apart
um all right this one's nicholas ever
use christmas lights as an extension
cord
which is
top-notch trash
i've never thought about dude if you if
you got a string of lights icicle lights
coming from the blender in the kitchen
that's a bad look yeah it's bad news i
never thought about that but it is
essentially just an extension cord
i will say this oh boy
if it was socially acceptable
i would have those white christmas
lights up most of the time and i would
have them running along the like the
baseboards
as extension cords but also using them
there's just something nice about when
when all the lights are off and just
little christmas lights are on tell me
it wasn't great in college when you had
them all around your [ __ ] dorm room i
would be lying to you
if i said we didn't still have
the christmas lights up at your house
right at our apartment
is it just lights or is it are they
mixed in with connected to the tree
garland i'm getting out kidding i'm
kidding is it like mixed in with garland
it's not garland so we have like one of
those like uh
it's like ivy i guess kind of i don't
know what kind of plan it is right okay
uh and it's on like uh imagine like a
thing like this kind of right and that
lattice
maybe it's like one of those like
leaning ladder type things but it's big
it's bigger than that you strung some
christmas lights and the the thing like
falls the leaves fall all the way down
to the grill like it's it's like the ivy
walk i got you and then we have the the
bird that lights in that during
christmas
and i it looks nice but i also don't
want to untangle it from the now the
plant's all
grown through it i'm like well let's
just staying there no that doesn't look
nice it's nice lights out you got that
going maybe a little manhattan in a
glass makes you feel good i'm telling
you yeah yeah but going from like the
two we also put them on the fire escape
and haven't taken them down yet though
either really yeah
i don't know how i feel about that
either i'm not against that are you
hanging on the fire escape no it's way
too high
it's
way too high dude
i have to put a number on it dumping
fish grease over to over the side it's
gotta try in the five t-shirts he wears
first of all i have about 70 of these
shout outs to freshcleant.com
hey jackay
how's your mind doing shall right
it's no it's like
oh you haven't been in my it's [ __ ]
it's well over 120 feet high
what floor are you on i'm on the six but
it's up that hill nah get the [ __ ] out
so but our building wait you're looking
out over the hill the back looks out
over the hill so where are you going
when you get down to the bottom of the
fire escape anyway you just falling down
the cliff
because that's how no for some reason
there's a you get to the back of the
building for some reason for the
listener
for some reason washington heights is
built it's like cliffs it's built on a
hill and it looks like a swiss fortress
most places there's these huge
brick walls that then hold up
like [ __ ] thousands picture the joker
building
yeah that's exactly i mean that's in the
bronx but picture that like
i live right next to a set of those so
it's like this huge
it's like an 80-foot cliff and then i'm
on top of the the back of my building is
exposed yeah i wouldn't go out there
those fire escapes ain't that safe
either no it's like do those who don't
check those things in who god knows how
long months
months [ __ ] that
my lady will pop out for like am i easy
yeah i don't like it [ __ ] i get that
feeling in my belly button don't like
the heist i told you that one time we
went to hawaii i was we were on like the
33rd floor
of this [ __ ] high-rise and we were on
the corner that wind was whipping out
there i wouldn't even go out on the
balcony it was terrifying
like no shot
like you're you're gonna drift as you
fall
have you ever been up in like the sears
tower or like a really tall building
where you see the water in the bathrooms
swishing in the toilets oh i don't like
that horrifying i'm out
what the [ __ ]
did
i'd run down the stairs
are you okay that's the first sign
it's going
you carry your goddamn mind
the water's swaying around
later
yeah
i i'll freak out if i look like when we
go do like serious and stuff that's on
like the 33rd floor or whatever
and even if you get too close to that
window that's like
like that [ __ ] sucks yeah you feel it
in your bp
yeah i don't like it yeah give me the
[ __ ] it's not for me
um
let's see here uh
this is from rick haven't had one read
yet ever by medical equipment from
craigslist
[Laughter]
i don't know what kind of equipment
you're talking about but it's probably
not a great look
my mom came home with some m95s i don't
know where should i come up at yeah
there's like a brown paper bag oh that's
bad
i used to do a decent amount i've bought
and sold a good amount of stuff off
craigslist
i quit like you know [ __ ] snowboards
or [ __ ] like that like furniture but it
was somewhat legit when it was talking
about college yeah it was okay but um
now it's like the dark web now it's
facebook marketplace though i bought all
this [ __ ] on [ __ ] facebook
marketplace the table [ __ ] you know
all this [ __ ] easy peasy
and you haggle real hard that's a good
way because you can get them it sucks
craigslist stinks cause you gotta copy
the email go into your thing and then
like you don't know who's selling what
or what they always just look so sketchy
it's usered a bunch of numbers i know
two of eight five nine seven b six
but i didn't like it facebook it's just
like a [ __ ] facebook message so
you're just
hey i'll give you 40. no okay next guy
hey i'll give you 20 or whatever you're
just [ __ ] beating them up real good
on price
which i don't like doing but on
the internet when i have i have the
power because i can just go buy the next
guy's [ __ ] coffee table or whatever
you know well when i wasn't sure if i
was going to be able to pull off getting
the cpap machine through my insurance
uh-huh i was looking at uh
some cpap going to black market
buying somebody's old used one the only
problem is they get set
to a certain parameter certain like
pounds per pressure or whatever the [ __ ]
it is that's not it but
a couple of foot pounds so you have to
you have to get it close to what yours
would be
so it would be a gamble like that but it
was almost a move yeah i don't mind i i
found jobs on craigslist i've done
everything
yeah i mean it was one of the craziest
jobs i ever had for sure only lasted two
weeks i needed that paid training was
real important people eating sushi off
of you at a party
he got a whole mackerel on his floor
yeah it was under the gig [ __ ] the
gig section
um
no that was the one where i was under
the overpass remember we've talked we
talked about i believe under the
overpass and it was paid training
no yeah did your pump and dump scam
the donation benevolent brothers
association yeah yeah
i thought if you're looking around
the guy who interviewed the guy who
interviewed me was wearing a visor
uh i believe with that fake hair woven
into it you know what i mean
that's like a thing like as a joke
i think he just wore it he wore a visor
his name was like docker wait they sell
wig hat combo yeah type visor with wig
really you see it damn yeah this thing
is crazy dude yeah it's like it looks
like something you look like guy fieri
or whatever a lot of them are like the
bleach blonde it's like bald guys in
florida having fun i think i don't know
i don't think it's serious but he wore
one all the time and a wife beater and
uh snow camo shorts when he
he interviewed me i have a i have a
degree in business from temple
university fox school of business and
there's a guy with a wig a wife peter
and snow camo cargo shorts interviewing
me for a sales position
yeah yeah it was tough you're selling
temple like it's harvard
compared to a guy in a white leader with
a wig on he was probably a professor
there he was a professor a heroine that
guy
this i knew it was a bad job my boss had
a job
another job
[Laughter]
the owner of the company
had a day job
dude
how crazy is he i remember i was like
where's steve after i thought he's
working i'm like what and he showed up
in like a uniform from
somewhere guys want some big doubles
i remember being like
man if the top of the food chain of this
business has a second job
or it was just like this isn't gonna
work out this is not good
man so i quit but i needed that that
paid training it's 500 bucks a week for
two weeks
paid training i just quit
fired for my family's company
and uh
i needed that cash kip i love bombas
absolutely fantastic here's the scoop
gang bomba's mission is simple make the
most comfortable clothes ever and match
every item sold with an equal
item and then donate it
so when you buy bombs you're also giving
to someone in need pretty cool we're
also
supposed to read that line and did it
bob has designed their sock shirts and
underwear to be the clothes you can't
wait to put on every day everything is
soft seamless tagless and it has a
luxurious feel that you know i'm big on
luxurious i make a nice pair of socks
i'll tell you that right now
the t-shirts are made with thoughtful
design features like invisible seams
soft fabrics and the perfect weight so
they hang just right start uh go to
bombas.com garbage to get twenty percent
off your first purchase i'm talking five
ain't talking 10 15 20 off your first
purchase that's b o m b a s dot com
garbage for twenty percent off bomas.com
[Music]
this stuff sells itself yeah because
it's absolutely fantastic
they sent it to us yeah all right
pre-portioned uh-huh all the ingredients
yes things i wouldn't even think to know
where to get where do you where do you
get nutmeg i don't know where's that
next to the frozen pizza i don't know
but they send it herbs spices vegetables
accoutrement all this stuff everything's
portioned out you whip it up save time
save money delicious delicious meals yes
hellofresh has fit and wholesome recipes
for satisfying and nutritious meals that
make you feel good about make you feel
good about with six risk six recipes a
week to choose from someone
someone resent me including low calorie
and carb conscious options
uh hellofresh also offers flexibility if
you need easily customized if you need
to easily customize your order online or
in the app easily change your delivery
day your food preferences oh yeah skip a
week like we were like we use i'll go on
the road we're going on the road punt it
till now pause it till next week they do
have the app down pretty good they know
what they're doing uh like you said
we've done it me and my wife it's it's a
little zest little little spice to the
to the romance too you're in it's stuff
that you were both topless you know
little bottle of wine so go to
hellofresh.com garbage16
use code garbage16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts these people
are giving it away go to hellofresh.com
garbage16 use code garbage 16 for up to
16 free meals and three free gifts do it
now back to the show back to the show
that was when you were lending me money
i lent you money you left me 20 bucks i
think i ever get it back
yes
let me check a couple let me check last
month's bank transfers yeah you got it i
don't think so you did
what's the interest on that how many
years ago was this it was before
if you asking for a 20 there's no way i
ever asked for it back
okay well there's been times where i've
given you 20 bucks too sure yeah of
course yeah that's what i would never i
don't think i don't think it was like
pitter-pat but like i've definitely
i've definitely i mean we've talked
about i've greased you to go tip someone
else on top of it sure of course yeah
yeah
we have that kind of relationship oh i
would never ask for you no but i
remember when you were living with uh
you were living in that south philly
apartment uh-huh with the the other
comedian it was alex and someone else
pearlman yeah it was me pearlman and uh
tiny street
ah
i'm drawing a blank
miquel carter jackson yeah
yeah the three boys because that was the
first time i played that uh that batman
arkham aside that place smelled so bad
no he walked into the freezer like oh
come on in dude i made it like into like
like the the doorway i was like i'll be
outside dude it was a tough look foley
just invented a new kind of fart
no there was like there was a cat
situation there but not a good one yeah
no no i wasn't playing the piano yeah no
it was [ __ ] it smelled like a [ __ ]
like he died a couple of weeks ago it
smelled like the green mile at the aspca
it was [ __ ] tough um but i remember
going down there to pick up 20 bucks
from you
really yeah damn that's how that's how
jammed up i was what a loser i mean we
were two we used to be so poor
i'm running out in my robe to hand you
20. yeah i'm thinking you're a real shot
coming i'll give you a sig here take
these
i'm [ __ ] doing you
oh you stink
that and i remember i would have to
facebook you when i wanted to talk
because my phone will get shut off all
the time uh still does for i just like
three months ago i set it up on
automatic payment but i would get
shut off all the
um
time
phone getting shut off oh i would just
well i mean up until a year ago i really
couldn't
pay it consistently should upgrade to a
family plan um
you can really tell how jammed up
someone is by how quickly they ask you
for the wi-fi password oh yeah that's
yeah you got the wi-fi password
what's the wi-fi here
i have a couple hot sauce the second you
walk into a place yeah
ricky velez has a joke about that
you know your friends aren't doing well
the second they walk into a party they
ask for a charger
super funny
that's all so bad
um
or you're hanging out with the wrong
people when people when your squad's
doing that or something but i would have
to facebook message you yo call me
because i could only receive call for
like once they shut your phone down i
[ __ ] completely forgot about that
holy [ __ ] they went watching i forgot
that that was a thing you'd get put on
like probation once you want your once
you watch pricks once you don't pay your
bill you can't make outward calls and
texting doesn't work but i guess for
like emergency purposes for like a day
or two there's like a grace period where
you can receive calls so i would
facebook that's like prince
yeah did the phone plans still do that
can they do that still no they shut you
down pretty too sweet right now really
[Laughter]
i know from you that was even more
[ __ ] up you'd be at halftime
still be presentable and i would always
post on facebook my phone's on the fritz
call me or whatever
hey phone's all [ __ ] up texts aren't
working call me yeah this rice doesn't
work i don't know what the deal is
anyway call me not one of my prouder
moms yikes
i am what i am give me that 20 when you
have it
[Laughter]
see
look at that what uncle house holding up
the building at one point then you moved
into my basement apartment became
roommates that we i mean yeah no we were
not roommates
i think you had to get out of that cat
situation and i had a cold floor you
could sleep on
there's a big difference between us
being roommates and you moving into my
apartment looking for something with
cold tile next to a broken water heater
sleep like a baby oh that's great
um
all right let's see here um
this is from cousin jeffrey are you or
are you or one of your garbage buddies
the guy who always gives the middle
finger in pictures
i was that guy for a long time and it's
still it's i'm not proud of it and it's
still n it's still kind of my go-to
sometimes like ah
i'm not
it's not good it's not good there's a
lot of pictures of me
i guess like in my probably my facebook
profile like you know tags or whatever a
lot of cigs in the mouth like a red cup
and
the finger real couple of mohawks too
two polo shirts pop collar never to polo
fox school of business huh yeah
this guy hey panned out all right for
you fatty
we'd both be living in that basement if
it wasn't for this goddamn degree
cats climbing over us
you got 10 20
yeah it's tough it's tough to look back
too because we were the first ones with
those digital cameras and facebook like
my generation was like it came out
facebook came out i think my s
my freshman year of college it still
wasn't real to you guys you still didn't
know like
about like your
online image sure you know what i mean
that like this is gonna be around
literally forever you're like we're
partying who cares you're at college you
know
some broad's got one of those silver
digital cameras she's going to take a
bunch of pics and go upload them yeah
until you're sick i remember when the
iphone dropped i was at a college party
you're sitting in front of congress you
got one of those pictures up on a
powerpoint you jenko jeans pooka
necklace red cup never bleach blonde
hair never giving the finger
i was an express button up man or a polo
are you looking at facebook pictures i'm
hitting the archives wow
oh well let's go to toby's then too
stupid all right yeah you were probably
like throwing motof cocktails and [ __ ]
like that you just got real boston on it
hey billy bobby johnny jimmy tommy
[ __ ] antifa andy over here running
around
dressed all in black
dirtbag
why do you go back to jazz
[Laughter]
what's jazz it's not like
that demilitarized zone in seattle or
whatever i don't i don't know enough
about anything
i just found a gem and it's on screen
right now let me see what is it i'll
text it to you what am i wearing uh
you're wearing a quarter zip uh
sweatshirt okay white tee
the flash red eyes in the flash like a
raccoon
how is that not fixed by now it still
does that on my [ __ ] iphone yeah but
there's a thing you can take it out i
think on youtube it looks cheesy when
you do that what the [ __ ] with the we
still got red eye
these guys are [ __ ] going to mars we
still got red eyes come on what are we
doing really taking it to us huh
we're following really tackling the big
issues over here
i got hot takes i mean the guy's 400
pounds he's worried about red eye
this is something i got to deal with
when i look like a fat tubby [ __ ] in my
pictures
i mean i'm hideous to begin with but now
my eyes are red yeah no [ __ ] uh did you
send it to me toby yeah i just liked it
too oh no i sent it to luke [ __ ] oh
great now i got my employees talking
[ __ ] on me wow your center you sent it
to new guy luke that'll be a good test
to see how he reacts yeah [ __ ] that guy
yeah yeah yeah you got a text back
i'm gonna text him hey so what's new
it's like it's like weird and
threatening to send him to because it's
you flipping them off
this is what kippy thinks of your work
we love you luke oh yeah
that was all right that was a good time
i was a good kid he just texted back
picks pick just screams [ __ ] off [ __ ]
yeah he gets it i am what i am what do
you want what are you well just go back
to your archives you think they're all
good talk about punch me in the face
[ __ ] well you were like 38 when this
picture was taken yeah no [ __ ] i was
probably picturing my family
he got lincoln park written all over you
in that picture what do you mean lincoln
where was that at where was that taken
at that looks to me let me see it again
that looks to me
that's a clothesline behind you yeah
with a towel you're in somebody's
backyard i believe parents probably
aren't home
that's probably something that's college
that's some poor girl babysitting you
guys are out there no that's college
babysitting i don't know i mean i was 21
in that picture probably
you know sure you were someone's parents
were probably aware we were hanging in
the backyard of someone's you know it
seemed like the pool's out there's a
towel hanging was there a lot of teenage
was there a lot of angst in in your life
at that time is that why you you yeah
one
no i don't know again we don't know what
this dude digital cameras just got to
the point where they weren't like this
big and like girls could carry them in
their purse i thought i was a tool cool
guy were you listening to a lot of
metallica at the time no this was
hip-hop you angry at the world no it
looks like you're going like this this
is the finger that touched the boob
i swear to god it was just one i swear
[Laughter]
oh i didn't um yeah
a young kippy hairline was all right let
me see it again i can't really tell all
right that's slipping i don't know about
that it was slipping in my 20s yeah for
sure the writing was on the wall if you
know what i mean
um
this one's just funny this is from
andrew i haven't had one read yet has
your uncle or aunt ever asked you to
borrow money that you know you won't see
again and they spelled borrow wrong
that's just good i've never had to let
an inner and uncle money no but that's a
tough look
someone just messaged me it was on
[ __ ] instagram or something i don't
know where it was
hence while patreon's the easiest way to
field them there's a way to submit but
um
he was like is it trash if my mom's if i
have to keep lending money to my mom's
new boyfriend
that's a bad look
if there's some new guy coming around
you got to spot him 20. yeah get your
phone cut back off plus now he's not
going to go anywhere he knows you're
[ __ ] ripe for it
that's crazy yeah it's a tough look i've
been that guy
what
once you know once you find a mark you
stick with it yeah you could borrow
something off the side i've been trying
to shake you for a decade
you keep going it's a sickness i don't
know what to tell you yeah
that's not good and no i've never had to
loan any anywhere i'm the biggest loser
in my family
45 years
i said that like i just got a promotion
now i'm the [ __ ] loser undefeated mvp
every year too i'm the borrower yeah
so am i yeah yeah never the lender
no definitely wasn't i'm definitely i
get eyes out i actually wasn't paying
off [ __ ] scratch-offs on the spot
i get eyes if i try to pick up a tab now
people are like all right i got like
dude you know i mean it went from like
it went from people making jokes that i
wouldn't pick it up because i just i
didn't have any money so i went to like
the point of like we're not like
we've made every joke what are we gonna
say we know what the score is here this
how this is how much of a bozo i am and
obviously and look like a bozo went out
to dinner uh the other night with my
family okay where'd you go
uh the place uh in the suburbs in philly
okay um
what i don't know why do you get so
weird about
the place in the suburbs outside of
philly because no one's gonna know it a
place called myrna's in bluebell it's
delicious it's a spot that i enjoy
sounds like a skin rash
[Laughter]
myrna's not it's top quality
mediterranean food it's actually
delicious
anyway
um
the whole big table
all right
i i get i'm taking care of the check
it's been established you know when
the whole thing i'm taking care i got
down there
listen i'm coming down here
so you said let me take you out to
dinner yes okay yeah i said listen i'm
taking mom and dad out to dinner you
know ask my brother and family do you
want to go my cousin ended up coming it
was nice [ __ ] whole big table it was
nice
um what are we talking bill here we'll
get to it but uh i'm ordering the apps
so it's like what do you guys want for
apps and just i'm just i'm just gonna
order i'll get it you know one thing i'm
ordering the abs and my brother felt
like i was ordering too much and he goes
no no no he's like just get one muscle
just get one muscles and the server
looked at him and goes yeah just one and
listen to what he said like i'm a
[ __ ] loser he see he knows
he's got a nice polo shirt on nice
[ __ ] wad there's just a dynamic if
that guy looks like he's got a little
bit of e if that guy at the table versus
you
that was the one that ended up paying
she first of all she don't know that i
know also you look like a guy who's
going to order double the appetizers
so just yeah like he said we got three
tunas one to go
watch for the cat fire to one fire to
one late um
yeah that's tough that's that's a tough
look
ran about five bills whoa what it was
look at you valentine's day you know
everybody was good your parents what you
know it was just nice
okay but i get looks
oh you shouldn't be doing that you can't
be doing
you're going to be hitting them up in a
couple of weeks well yeah you know i
mean also you still are on their family
plan
driving their car you're strengthening
the family bond it's like you think oh
you you need me i'm here if i ever need
you i'm there for you you want anybody
to know that
a couple of face throws never hurt
either
they're goddamn right 500 of these
almost five bills
you're asking your brother what's that
say how much is that i got it was that a
five
oh that's good yeah
um
all right this one's from mcliven i
don't know um
am i garbage for bringing an open
container of chips and dip to my buddy's
party
yeah that's bad that's that's a bad
level of that's real bad the only way i
don't it's subject it it's it's suspect
to bring the chips and the salsa still
to be what do you mean quite a
yeah that's really the bear it's a dip
chips and dip but also that stuff has to
be done
so someone says yeah just grab the chips
and dip you're right that's like that's
what they need what are you gonna make
[ __ ] souffles or whatever do you
think every party needs to have chips
and salsa not salsa chips in some sort
of dip if we're doing a pita and [ __ ]
hummus or if we're doing [ __ ]
charcuterie a couple meats and cheeses
little piece of bread cracker something
something buffalo chicken dip floating
around there this weekend
[Music]
i remember the first time i i dropped it
on some of my i dropped it on some of my
buddies it was pretty big in my family
before it popped everywhere like it was
like kind of it wasn't it wasn't
national no they weren't playing
it wasn't even families certain people
that it hadn't ever had i've given it to
my friends the first time
and then
my buddy gooch goes who made the crack
he's like this stuff is [ __ ] crazy
and a bag of scoops couple of [ __ ]
chippy dippies in there
yeah that's all right um
you know what my family does
what was that
the big man's on goofball i was gonna
say but opened and opened no so listen
the only way that's not even legal you
can't serve that legally the only way i
would maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
consider it as if
you got it you had a bag and a half
hear me out i don't agree with this but
if you were like i wasn't sure if one
bag was gonna be enough and i had this
at my house if the chips are open yeah
dip no way oh that's what i thought the
dip was this says chips and dip
now that's insane
you're coming in with [ __ ] both of
them the only way the chips could be
open is if they were extra if there are
additional chips on just to cover your
bases you got to put those out while
everyone's backs is turned or in an
empty kitchen grab a bowl and dump them
something what i was going to say is you
got a whip you got to take out the
[ __ ] dip the divots in the hummus too
you got to whip that up
get the orange if you look like someone
took a nine-iron get the oreo crumbs out
of there
yeah get somebody to attend to the
greens yeah uh here's a dirt ball tip if
you're ever in that situation you get
hemmed up you got to show up with
something
take the salsa or or whatever the dip it
is and put it into it to go container
give it a little [ __ ] hit or even a
bowling whatever you would serve at your
house put it in the tinfoil then hit it
with a little
yeah
the chips i would transfer them into
something else too that's a tough one i
mean if i show up to a party someone
pulls out ziploc chips i'm out chips in
a pillowcase yeah that's the second
location i'd rather have them in the
original bag not knowing it can i can
kind of i can kind of hope that they
got opened when you got there how do you
guys feel about the homemade french
onion dip with the sour cream in the
packet yeah it's [ __ ] fantastic yeah
that's been a while i was 90. the lipton
onion thing you mix it with sour cream
i've said this many times on this
broadcast i believe also the way to go
with [ __ ] ranch dip is the hidden
valley ranch packet mixed into a [ __ ]
tub of sour cream it's blow your hair
back good
oscar-worthy
fantastic
uh what is your number one dipping chip
ruffle
no but i know i see that's where your
head's at because the number one dipping
chip for that french onion dip is a uh
a straight up potato chip but but ridged
yeah the rich ones we would do otts
would be the ripples
um not a ruffles guy except for the sour
cream and cheddar
that's all right that gives me reflux
anymore though
it's tough they just it's like too tangy
or something i've never heard somebody
call it reflux
okay
uh just reflect sound like a robot
what up my boy reflux um messing up your
process you know what we do we're big on
at the uh
ryan kelly sullivan's household
a lot of dirtbags where's history now
it's like an irish law firm
talking to ryan sullivan and kelly
[Laughter]
we'll get you convicted
are you arrested in dui
um
you know what joke i heard recently i
think it was an snl it was they it was
the law firm of do we cheat him and hal
sure that's a great one that's like
dewey cheatham and howl
that's a good time
um we'll do
uh like the little circle like the
shallow circles with uh
olive oil in them slice up some bread
and then they have like the spices for
like it's like dipping
it's like oil with spices that you dip
the bread in mm-hmm pretty good what are
the circles ramekin nah it's not like a
ramek it's like a shallow dip it's not a
ramekin does it come with the bread in
it is it single serving that's where the
oil goes where in the shallow tray the
shallow dish yes it's a ramekin for
arguments but a big one no they're like
this big ah okay they're not individuals
though what aren't individuals the
ramekins you don't get like a piece of
bread in the little thing like that
no that wouldn't make any sense i didn't
know yeah no you dip it in okay those
are filled with oil and spices uh-huh
have you not seen this i don't
understand what's going on i don't know
what you're talking about i'll be dead
honest with you okay there's like a
small dish
and or ramekin if that's easier for you
you fill that with olive oil there's a
couple of them yeah and then the couple
different seasoning ones yes and then
you put the seasoning in the olive oil
just for bread yeah i mean i see that on
the table but i would never see that
wouldn't be on like a party tray or like
on a party table
i wouldn't say party table this is like
if i if like if you're having dinner at
the house before it's not a party okay
that makes sense okay it's not like next
to the cheese curls or anything
no it's not next to the cheese girls is
that what is that what you're doing at
parties cheese girls sometimes oh my god
on the guy who hasn't been to a party in
30 years that's not true i've seen
cheese girls at a party recently so what
are the the doritos in a basket with a
napkin or what's going on here
what are these cool ranch ones ah
all right let's do one or two more then
we gotta get out of here please
this is a home run it's from david smith
uh just says display to finished puzzle
question mark
never finished the puzzle oh yeah i
don't we were never even a puzzle family
never i don't even think we've ever
attempted one the last time i did them
the puzzle pieces were like that big
yeah like the big one i think they were
made out of styrofoam or something it
was like some kitty thing yeah yeah yeah
never yeah never
they tried to get my dad to start doing
them a couple years ago but that lasted
for about two seconds i'm telling you
erotic photo hunt for him would be all
right
now no good puzzles
i know people that would like
lacquer them and like keep them together
and then put them up on the wall
never never never oh this is real yeah
obviously you frame them this just
reminded me
remember that
we did have a 3d puzzle
what the hell is that
anything you remember those the 3d
puzzles they were like buildings it was
like a it was like a skyscraper or
something oh okay and it had like a
street or something my stepdad tried
like yeah check this out like
buddy kick rock make good with the
scratchers what are we doing here
[ __ ] i'm not an architect over here
i'm a degenerate gambler you owe me like
two payouts let's go
wasting your money on this junk
no models when you were a kid right
i think i've actually done this yeah you
told me your brother got into him no i
know but you didn't do them no all right
okay cut this out yeah
all right let's do one more and then
wrap it up um
this is from ethan never had a question
read have you ever had your iphone face
id stop working because you your face
got too fat damn that's gonna happen
i think so yeah i don't i don't [ __ ]
with the face id but yeah i think you
know if you look like a different person
certain apps check me every once in a
while i got to do it once or twice they
take a second look
wait a minute yep still him [ __ ] foley
is that you
god damn i get it every once in a while
yeah no i don't i don't mess i don't
trust that technology i don't want them
having my face wait so you don't wait
you don't have that on the apps where
you do the face no
you're typing it in every time typing
what in the password and for what apps i
don't know your banking
your banking app yeah
you type in the password every time i
type in the eight characters yeah you're
crazy i'm [ __ ] face ideal you also
stop texting and you just whatever text
conversation you're having everybody in
earshot also has to have that text
conversation with you okay i'm on my
wits the most egregious thing in the
world it is bus behavior oh it's [ __ ]
it's like dirt bag laziness
i'm okay buddy i'm all thank you so so
much
it stinks i have noticed it's been
getting annoying what you say something
to me
plus when i do it around my daddy
doesn't know what's going on yeah
i got to stop doing it yeah
i'm working on it all right let's wrap
it up we got to go gang we absolutely
love you kippy what do you got for him
uh at cameron comedy and also business
at cameron comedy on all social media
obviously patreon.com guys the tour is
full blown cooking come see us
come hang out
uh check us out uh
all the ayg social pages the whole nine
yards subscribe share a friend tell a
friend anything we love you thank you so
much see you next week subscribe to the
clip's channel instead of your buddies
yes we just we just launched a clip
channel new guy luke is working on the
clip channel so he's gonna be cranking
them out check it out uh we're operation
flood the block there's something going
on almost every day yeah we're dropping
a lot more content trying to get this
thing cookie cookie cooking there we go
we love you see you next week peace